in the year to March Royal Mail made an
operating profit of 416 million pounds
last year
344 million pounds why is it you say
there's no money to pay a decent cost of
living related increase
well Ian morning
um I think that I would like to start
today with an apology please for our
customers we understand how disruptive
the current situation is and I'd also
like to make it clear that the change
that we are asking for is the change
that our customers want which is a seven
day Parcel Service and including that
very important late night orders that
are delivered the next day
and I don't think we can ignore the
facts the facts are that we are losing
one million pounds a day and the other
fact is that strike action has cost us a
hundred million pounds a day so far
after eight days of strike action and
the other thing as well is that we have
put a offer on the table and enhanced
offer on the table over nine percent pay
deal over 18 months which is costing the
business 400 million pounds even though
we are losing that million pounds per
day we need to change we need to change
for our customers to give our customers
what it is that they need okay I mean I
get that Simon but the business has been
very profitable for the last two years
postal workers were asked to work
through the pandemic and and they did
that uncomplainingly why don't they
deserve a pay rise linked to the cost of
living now
well what I would say is that what we
are really focused on is giving the
customers what they want and I think
that in the context that we have of
losing a million pounds a day
now we all can see what's happening
around us both the cost of living crisis
that of course our team are not immune
to and the fact that the markets out
there is more challenging in the
recessionary reality is that our volumes
have come down these things are true but
what we want to do and what we're really
focused on is giving our customers what
it is that they need and I think we can
all see that the world has changed
around us we're all getting less letters
and people want more Parcels but within
that context what we need is the change
and we're happy to pay for the change
and the more change the more pay and we
feel that the nine percent pay deal
against our context of losing a million
pounds a day is incredibly fair and the
other thing I'd also like to add as well
Ian is that during our recent intensive
talks and a big thank you to a cast who
have been magnificent in terms of
supporting us you know we've also made
some key concessions based on what it is
that our team have asked for such as
voluntary working on a Sunday and even
if we had been talking last Friday and
you'd asked me
whether I was confident that we would
have had an agreement this week I would
have said yes
so what's gone wrong
well I think that's a great question Ian
and it's not one that I can actually
answer but what I would really encourage
the CWU to do is to reflect on what
changed since last Friday and perhaps
get themselves back in the mindset of
where we all were last Friday after some
very constructive and intensive talks
that even went over the weekends you
know and they've still got a chance to
save Christmas and their members jobs
and I would also just like to add you
know it's really important to emphasize
that more of our units are open today
and more of our people are actually back
at work today
you've talked about the need for
modernization Simon but I mean it's been
known for years it was known at
privatization that Royal Mail needed to
modernize why have you only just started
pushing through modernization in the
last year or so
well Ian I can only reflect on my time
as the chief executive over the last 20
months and you know we've invested 900
million pounds on the infrastructure to
win in the market you know we've our
beautiful super Hub in Warrington is up
and running is ramping up to plan you
know we we have Parcels automation that
was less than 30 percent uh less than
two years ago we're now at the 70
percent uh Mark and I was at our super
Hub in the Midlands as well which means
we can really compete and win in the
parcels market and that was looking
magnificent as well and that will come
on stream in the summer so what I am
really focused on is what's ahead of us
and what I would say is that our
customer experience on the doorstep
remains really great the citizens advice
uh did a survey last week and we are
number one versus our competitors and a
big thank you to our team for making
that happen on the doorstep as well our
infrastructure is coming on stream
exactly as we planned the problem to
solve is the ways of working and we are
happy to pay for that change and that's
why we have offered a 400 million pounds
worth of nine percent pay increase over
the next 18 months now your parent
company International distribution
services has been talking increasingly
about spinning off GLS which is the very
profitable International Parcels
business what sort of Future Would a
standalone Royal Mail have under those
circumstances
well Ian what I'm focused on is turning
around Royal Mail in the UK and you know
I said it very very clearly last year at
a half year results that I will do and
we will do whatever it takes
we did say uh back at our AGM earlier on
in the year that of course all options
are open and we won't cross subsidize
between GLS our international business
and Royal Mail in the UK but look I'm
focused on the turnaround and what we
need is the change to win and compete in
the market and I've always been
confident that we can do just that our
customer experience is great our
infrastructure is coming on stream what
we need is the ways of working to
reflect that and we've always said we're
happy to pay for it for that and that is
exactly what our deal is about well
something else that could really uh
benefit you is a watering down of the
universal service obligation which
obviously costs you a great deal of
money I mean that's in the gift of the
government what doesn't the government
get about the need to uh alter the terms
of the Uso
well in terms of the Uso there are two
key criterias that need to be met one is
that it's financially viable and one
that it meets the needs of the customers
I think if we start with the needs of
the customers I mean ofcom did their own
review there's some time back that said
that a five-day letter service would
meet 97
um of you know customers needs it's also
worth bearing in mind and I think we can
all see that in terms of our own
letterboxes but in 2004 2005 we
delivered 20 billion letters a year it's
now 8 billion and actually during covert
the letter decline was around about 25
percent
and what the customers also say is they
want a seven day parcel business I think
in terms of the financial viability side
of stuff you know we're losing a million
pounds a day this year we're forecast to
lose between 350 and 450 million pounds
a day what we want to do is make sure
we're doing the right thing for the
customers which is a seven day Parcel
Service and make sure that's what we're
investing in and we're spending our time
also on what customers want and not on
what customers no longer want
all right so I mean Before I Let You Go
um should I be posting any presents that
I buy online now in order to them having
have giving them a chance of getting to
my loved ones by Christmas Day well Ian
I feel very sad to say what I'm going to
say and what I would you know be clear
is please go to our websites and and
have a look at the latest information
and we will do everything that we can
and a big thank you to our
non-operational managers who are out and
about delivering today but I would say
to everyone please post early for
Christmas
now Simon no we spoke to Dave Ward from
the CW earlier I mean you talked about
uh having held discussions with them
over the weekend he's he told us on Sky
news this morning he'd be prepared to
meet with you today or tomorrow is that
possible
and we are always available to talk but
I just want to make it really clear that
we have been talking intensively over
the last three weeks with the help of
acas
um including all of the weekends and we
have now made our final offer so what I
would really encourage the CWU to do and
actually the CW leadership to do is
really take the chance now to reflect
and reflect on saving Christmas and
their members jobs and I really hope
that they make the right decision